hovering above the water delicate like a
glass tent yet powerful like a steamer
gliding up the Elbe River after ten
years of construction and at a price tag
ten times the original estimates the
Elbphilharmonie is finally finished
there's been no shortage of controversy
but few would dispute the brilliance of
building it atop an old warehouse in
Hamburg sport here in half is nothing
it's an unusual building for here in the
harbor although many buildings here are
brick this one is from the 1960s and in
its radical almost forbidding stance it
was really a wonderful foundation for
this concert hall which is so different
from the norm on both earth
the entrance is via the so called cube
the 80 metre long escalator cuts through
the old warehouse bringing visitors up
into the foyer
apartments concert hall
luxury hotel all side-by-side with a
stunning view out over the city there's
an anaconda stopped yeah it is like a
little city where everything comes
together on a dockside warehouse and
where people of all generations and
different interests can go to a new
space basically I know your plot
thoughts Asarco our path leads us
through the plaza into the heart of the
Elbphilharmonie the Great Hall
it seems reserved intimate completely
and utterly focused on its raison d'être
the music
[Music]
musicians from the Elbe Philharmonic
Orchestra have been rehearsing here
since November to get a feel for the
acoustics on Basim today I had
misgivings at first that people would be
disappointed both by the aesthetics as
well as the acoustics because
expectations are so incredibly high but
I have to say I was blown away when I
came in here we're not allowed to film
during rehearsals the sound qualities
the halls last great secret now the
arguments over cost and aesthetics are
water under the bridge and soon we'll
know if the acoustics are on par with
the architecture